[Música]
en menos de una hora empiece en eeuu el
esperado cara a cara entre el
republicano donald trump y su rival
demócrata joe biden en el primer debate
presidencial que se transmitirá desde
cleveland
ambos candidatos hablarán entre otros
temas sobre las declaraciones de
impuestos del mandatario la gestión de
la pandemia el relevo en la corte
suprema y la ola de protestas anti
racistas continúan los combates en el
sur del cáucaso azerbaiyán y los
separatistas armenios aceptaron pérdidas
en ambos bandos en el tercer día de
intensos combates armenia denuncia que
turquía participó en el ataque de uno de
esos aviones militares al cara lo niega
más de 32 mil muertos en perú forman
parte del millón de fallecimientos que
hay en el mundo por el coronavirus los
médicos peruanos iniciaron una nueva
huelga para exigir mayor seguridad en el
trabajo tenemos reporte desde lima
hola como estan saludamos con mucho
gusto a todos ustedes que nos siguen por
la señal de france 24 mi nombre es alan
austria y hoy que es martes sean
bienvenidos todo listo para que donald
trump y joe biden se vean cara a cara en
su primer debate presidencial durante 90
minutos los candidatos abordarán temas
clave como la gestión del cob y 19 y los
disturbios al margen de las protestas
contra la brutalidad policial y el
racismo pero una más reciente cuestión
aumenta las tensiones las recientes
revelaciones del 'new york times' sobre
las finanzas de trump que no habría
pagado impuestos en 11 de los 18 años
examinados por el diario andrés meza
muñoz tiene los detalles
donald trump y job aiden debatirán
frente a frente por primera vez y las
recientes revelaciones sobre las
finanzas de chrome amenazan con calentar
el debate a favor de los demócratas el
new york times obtuvo las declaraciones
de impuestos del mandatario y divulgó
que no pagó nada durante una década y
sólo aportó 750 dólares en 2016 y lo
mismo en 2017 tras llegar a la casa
blanca rahm se limitó a decir que son
noticias falsas aprovechando la
situación joe biden y su fórmula
vicepresidencial kamala harris hicieron
públicas sus declaraciones de impuestos
sólo el año pasado el líder demócrata
pagó unos 288 mil dólares la pandemia es
otro de los grandes focos los demócratas
han culpado al presidente por la crisis
generada a raíz del virus
trump siempre abogó por un rápido
levantamiento de las restricciones para
salvar la economía aún cuando la
enfermedad avanzaba con rapidez y hoy
hay más de 7 millones de casos y más de
200.000 muertes el debate también estará
enmarcado por las protestas contra la
discriminación racial y la brutalidad
policial sin embargo el tema ha sido
simplemente nombrado como raza y
violencia en nuestras ciudades lo que se
considera una inclinación a favor de
trump
de la cadena 'fox medio cercano a los
republicanos trump ha tratado de
persuadir a los votantes de que elegir a
su adversario sumiría al país en caos
mientras que bardem acusa al presidente
de alentar la violencia y no condenar
los ataques de supremacistas blancos la
puja sobre quién reemplazará a la
fallecida jueza ruth báder ginsburg en
la corte suprema también ha atizado el
debate entre ambos partidos
joe dominó a la conservadora miconi
barber y los liberales temen sobre un
retroceso en temas como el aborto los
antecedentes políticos de ambos
candidatos también están sobre la mesa
como las acusaciones de corrupción
contra los bardem y de interferencia
rusa a favor de trump para poder llegar
a la casa blanca y el cambio climático
puede ser el gran ausente del primer
debate presidencial y esto al tiempo que
los incendios siguen consumiendo la
costa oeste de eeuu con dos nuevos focos
de incendios en el norte del estado de
california hasta allí llegó nuestra
corresponsal susana mendoza
aunque no me parezca esto que se ve a
mis españa
un centro para evacuados está listo para
ayudar a miles de personas que están
yendo ahora mismo del incendio de glass
aquí en el norte de california es un
nuevo incendio que a mí
el valle de napa y
elena que ha quedado en su parcialidad
también totalmente calcinada incluyendo
un famoso viñedo como el viñedo cowell
del que no ha quedado apenas más que
unas pocas piedras esta noche este lunes
por la noche en la ciudad de cali estopa
tengo que ser evacuada en su totalidad
las personas no tuvieron apenas más que
unos momentos para recoger sus
pertenencias y salir corriendo ahora
mismo se calcula que son casi 70.000
personas las que han tenido que ser
evacuadas desde este viernes
y no se pierdan hoy ya en unos 56
minutos a las 20 horas de bogotá actitud
y lima nuestra emisión especial dedicada
a este esperado debate con toda la
información y el análisis de los
especialistas
a unos otros temas y es que los combates
se intensificaron en el tercer día de
enfrentamientos entre las fuerzas de
azerbaiyán y los separatistas armenios
mientras las partes descartaron un
diálogo tras el llamado de países como
eeuu rusia y alemania- el consejo de
seguridad de la onu reclamó un cese
inmediato de los combates
el sonido de las bombas se ha vuelto
habitual en los últimos días la lucha
continúa en nagorno karabaj y tanto las
fuerzas de azerbaiyán y armenia buscan
mostrar cómo se golpean entre sí con
ataques aéreos
una guerra de propaganda con víctimas
reales que se acumulan en ambos lados
en la capital de azerbaiyán los hombres
hacen fila para enlistarse y unirse a la
primera línea de batalla
armada aunque nuestro ejército es fuerte
vine aquí a mostrar a nuestro gobierno
que estoy listo estamos listos para
proteger nuestra tierra en cualquier
momento en las calles de yereván los
armenios muestran sensaciones
encontradas no queremos guerra pero si
no las imponen vamos a pelear quiero que
todas las partes vuelvan a la mesa de
negociaciones lo único que deseo es paz
golpes el último estallido en un
conflicto de larga data inició el
domingo en nagorno karabaj región
declarada parte de azerbaiyán tras la
división de la unión soviética pero que
ha permanecido largamente bajo control
de separatistas armenios respaldados por
el gobierno
una guerra total terminó con alto el
fuego mediado por rusia en 1994 pero
ningún acuerdo de paz formal se firmó
desde entonces mientras eeuu en rusia y
alemania han pedido el cese de los
enfrentamientos
turquía aliado de azerbaiyán dijo estar
lista para ayudar a bakú a recuperar lo
que calificó como tierras ocupadas y
sólo 12 m bassets la solución al
problema es simple y hay una sola
armenia debe retirarse de los
territorios que ha ocupado en azerbaiyán
si eso no ocurre el conflicto no podrá
ser resuelto sin más
armenia acusó a turquía de derribar uno
de sus aviones de combate algo que
ankara niega de ser cierto derivaría en
una escalada significativa del conflicto
el gobierno griego dio el primer paso
para la descongestión del nuevo campo de
refugiados de lesbos con el traslado de
cientos de ellos al menos diez mil se
encuentran reubicados luego de los
incendios que devastaron su refugio en
moría frente a este campo nuestra
enviada especial eric a olavarría nos
informó la situación de emergencia a la
que se enfrentan estas personas me
encuentro frente al campo que los
inmigrantes y los griegos han comenzado
a llamar
moria 2.0 justamente es el campo de
refugiados que el gobierno griego ha
instalado aquí en la isla para intentar
relocalizar a las casi 13.000 personas
que vivían en el campo de moria que se
quemó hace justo tres semanas hoy
podemos visitar las ruinas de ese campo
donde todavía llegan migrantes buscando
algunas de sus pertenencias que se
salvaron de las llamas aquí detrás mío
muchos migrantes se negaron en un primer
momento a entrar sin embargo se dice que
ya hay casi 10.000 personas viviendo
allí viven en tiendas con poca
iluminación con algunas horas de agua al
día y sufren importantes controles
para evitar que traigan elementos
cortantes o inflamables y evitar un
nuevo incendio las personas se negaban a
entrar no sólo por las condiciones que
critican solamente por ejemplo tienen
una ración de comida diaria se les ha
separado por nacionalidades se ha
aislado también a muchos de ellos que
tienen 19 sino que también se negaban
porque ya no ven perspectivas muchos de
ellos llevaban meses viviendo aquí sin
una solución a su situación de asilo a
sus demandas por tener un estatuto de
refugiado en el 'viejo continente' por
primera vez en 19 años un presidente
francés viaja a lituania para una visita
bilateral pero de manuel macro ni su
homólogo gitanas now se da tuvieron como
principal tema el país vecino belarús
ambos mandatarios acordaron que la unión
europea debe imponer sanciones al país
dirigido por alexander lukashenko
en la primera etapa de su gira por los
países bálticos emanuel manjón se reunió
con su homólogo lituano gitanas now se
da en vilna este lunes el mandatario
francés también aprovechó su estadía en
la región más oriental de la unión
europea para visitar a la opositora
bielorrusa sviatlana tica nos calla
nos prometió hacer todo lo posible por
ayudar en las negociaciones durante esta
crisis política en nuestro país una
jugada de equilibrista de presidente
francés tratando de no descartar a rusia
de la mesa la oposición de sus hechos
nuestra visión es si queremos construir
una paz duradera en el continente
europeo tenemos que trabajar con rusia
porque compartimos una historia y una
geografía y compartimos esta historia a
veces para peor
jose tipo policía
por lo tanto marco encabezó junto a
gitanas now será un movimiento que
promueve la firmeza frente a alexander
lukachenko otros estados como éste que
superen en cuanto a belarús acordamos
que la unión europea no puede perder el
tiempo y tiene que hacer todo lo posible
para que las sanciones sean discutidas y
acordadas y sean confirmadas en la
próxima cumbre de los líderes de la ue y
luego en la reunión de los ministros de
relaciones exteriores de botón a truco
sostener y coveñas ministros de tiquina
en este asunto francia ya no está sola
mientras la unión europea toma la
decisión o no de sancionar a belarús
gran bretaña y canadá ya anunciaron este
martes medidas incluyendo la prohibición
de viajar y la congelación de activos de
ocho miembros del gobierno bielorruso
entre otros
lukachenko y su hijo
repasamos ahora las cifras que deja el
coronavirus a nivel mundial los
fallecimientos relacionados al cob y 19
ahora duplican el número de personas que
mueren anualmente de malaria esto
después de la mortalidad en las últimas
semanas con las que se superó el millón
de decesos mientras que los casos
globales rebasan los 33 millones 489 mil
de los que unos 23 millones 243 mil se
han recuperado
pero es el sexto país del mundo con más
casos de kobe 19 con unos 800 8000 los
médicos peruanos empezaron una huelga
este martes exigiendo mejoras salariales
y equipos de protección nuestro
corresponsal en lima francisco zacarías
estuvo con los médicos
los médicos del sistema nacional de
salud realizan un paro de 48 horas y
aunque aseguran que no descuidan la
atención de emergencias y casos de kobe
19 protestan por un cambio de los
hospitales también exigen mejores
condiciones laborales y salariales
además del pago de un bono cobit
exposición y riesgo de muertes nosotros
hemos tomado estas estas y esta protesta
de 48 horas porque el diálogo que hemos
tratado de mantener con la patronal
porque estos son patrones no son
gestores no hemos conseguido eco para
solucionar los problemas que aquejan a
diario los médicos los médicos hemos
pasado de ser una clase media vulnerable
a ser potencialmente pobres los médicos
rechazan la eficiencia del sistema
sanitario denuncian que ésta habría
impulsado casos de contagios y
fallecidos entre sus colegas pero otros
profesionales afirman que ya se están
comenzando a atender algunos reclamos
como el pago del bono covite
así como cumplir en una primera etapa la
vida en la segunda etapa en donde va a
seguir otorgando el bono mensualmente
ahora de que sería que salud no está
pagando lo solo eso es totalmente falso
de salud cumple todos los meses con el
pago de nuestros haberes y los
beneficios que esta ley a nadie se le ha
nadie se le ha recortado lógico que un
personal que está haciendo el trabajo
remoto y va a querer que le paguen
guardias nocturnas sin hacerlo también
es una aberración el paro médico se
produce cuando pero tiene más de 800
ocho mil contagiados y más de 32.000
fallecidos por el mortal patógeno
las autoridades peruanas han alertado
sobre una eventual segunda ola de la
pandemia del joven 19 dentro de dos o
tres semanas y cambiado la página para
finalizar en francia y es que de la
torre eiffel se venden toda clase de
productos derivados como pinturas o
llaveros pero este mes de septiembre la
torre sacó a la venta su propio vino su
nombre elche entonces este informe de
natalia ruiz
la gran dama como bodega para vinificar
vino su primera cosecha es un merlot la
bodega fue instalada en el primer piso
de la torre eiffel en octubre de 2019
ahora es tiempo de degustarlo mucha
elegancia y delicadeza con un modesto
grado de alcohol lo que lo hace muy
fácil de beber es taninos precisos bien
definidos que se integran muy bien en el
paladar
aquí mismo se embotella cada ejemplar
sólo unos pocos fueron convidados al
descorche de las primeras botellas de
este vino tinto orgánico han llegado a
57 metros de altura cuando hablamos de
parís de francia hablamos de la torre
eiffel
cuando hablamos de francia hablamos de
vino entonces cuando nos propusieron a
níjar vino en la torre eiffel en seguida
nos pareció una idea muy original y
original la apuesta del dom en la
burbuja es producir en parís un vino de
gran calidad asociando sus viñedos en
versalles al monumento más visitado del
mundo para conjugar turismo y enología
nuestro deseo era crear una bodega
funcional que permita crear un vino a la
altura de su reputación luego vinifica
mos la uva en estas barricas hechas a la
medida del montacargas de la torre
eiffel y que fueron instaladas
especialmente para crear la bodega de la
torre eiffel son cubas en forma de
tronco para vinificar con cuidado este
malo
en 2020 sólo saldrán 300 botellas del
pse de la tour eiffel vendidas en
estuche de lujo por 80 euros cada una
sólo podrán ser adquiridas en selectas
cavas parisinas
llegamos al final gracias por su
compañía siga con más en francés 24
[Música]